i know this has been a bit of a heavy
show gas prices going up you know what's
going on the people in charge seem to be
lying to us they have media people that
run cover for them uh so i thought we
could end with some hope right because
we need hope we need hope everyone needs
hope in these in these troubling times
and there's a woman
who is just she's just smart and she's
good and knowledgeable
and forthright and i think can help us
in the future
her name is kamala harris and everything
i just said there was a lie we're
screwed people take a look at this
imagine a future
the freight trucks that deliver bread
and milk to our grocery store shelves
and the buses that take children to
school and parents to work imagine all
the heavy-duty vehicles that keep our
supply lines strong and allow our
economy to grow imagine
that they produced zero emissions
well you all imagined it
that's why we're here today
because we have the ability to see what
can be
unburdened by what has been
and then to make the possible
actually happen
imagine people
there was a world that was made of
marshmallows and there were rainbows
that connected one marshmallow to
another marshmallow and those
marshmallows could combine and become a
bigger marshmallow and it's you people
who support marshmallows who allow us to
have two marshmallows connected by a
rainbow and smiles and happiness it's
all very wonderful
she's a heartbeat away from the
presidency she's a heartbeat away from
the presidency i would not trust that
woman to teach third graders
basic math
not that they're allowed to teach basic
math anymore but i just wouldn't allow
it anyway